Watch where you step,
people dump bodies out here sometimes.
We are building houses for the poor.
We are now finishing the first 600, but we're going to build 2000.
And where does the money come from?
HOLY SHIT!
One kilo is worth 7 thousand dollars here in Columbia,
In the United States, hundred and fifty thousand.
Do the math.
Despite our best efforts, illegal cocaine is coming into our country at alarming levels.
Let's make a deal. You will tell me your secrets and I'll tell you mine.
You two are involved.
Why don't you ask your friends at the CIA?
I will.
You have money, Pablo.
You have us, what more do you want?
I want respect.
"Long live the mothers of Colombia and the motherland."
Pablo Escobar Gaviria has been elected
I'm sorry sir but a tie is required to enter the Chamber.
This is a disgrace.
It is an insult to every Colombian.
It's time to start killing people.
So they learn to respect us.
In war, you can't win half way.
The Minister of Justice has been assassinated only minutes ago.
Only one thousand million pesos, only, they're insulting us.
Hand out guns in this land.
For every dead cop I will pay $2000.
For every captain, $20,000.
There are 500 men here to capture Pablo Escobar.
Sir, Escobar! Escobar!
Is he everywhere?
Things are going to get very complicated.
Miss Vallejo, help us find him.
Anybody listening?
Ay, ay, ay, I know that you are all there listening.
Now listen to me malparíos, everyone
I'm going kill you and your children and your wives
and you're going to bleed until you die.
Do you still love him?